so this morning our negotiating  team returned from london after a week  of  intensive negotiations they informed me  about the state of play  and the remaining divergences i had this  evening a phone call with prime minister  boris johnson  on the ongoing negotiations between the  european union and the united kingdom  we welcome the fact that progress  has been achieved in many areas  nevertheless  significant differences remain on the  three critical issues  level playing field governance and  fisheries  both sides underline that no agreement  is feasible  if these issues are not solved  and whilst recognizing the seriousness  of these differences we agreed that a  further effort should be undertaken by  our negotiating teams  to assess whether they can be these  issues can be resolved  we're therefore instructing our chief  negotiators to reconvene tomorrow in  brussels and  i will speak again to prime minister  boris johnson on monday evening  thank you